Eventually humans stop growing, I'm pretty
tall, but I'll never get any taller, only
shorter.
Sharks?
They just keep.
Getting.
More.
AWESOME.
Earlier this month, photographers filmed the
largest great white shark ever spotted in
the wild.
Most great whites normally grow 12 to 14 feet
long (3.6-4M), but this one, named Deep Blue,
was 20 feet long (6M)!
The director of a non-profit that supports
Pacific marine species, like these sharks,
says seeing one so large means hope for these
animals.
Sharks live a long time, 73 years, and a 2014
paper in Marine & Freshwater Research found
sharks can take 23 to 33 years to reach full
maturity.
Human size is set from birth.
We grow until we reach a genetically pre-determined
size and then we stop.
As we go through puberty, our body begins
to make sex hormones like estrogen -- both
men and women produce estrogen, women just
have more.
Estrogen ultimately makes the growth plates
of our bones fuse, stopping growth forever.
But that doesn't happen in sharks -- they'll
keep growing after maturity until they die,
just more slowly.
Based on her size, Deep Blue is probably 50
years old; bigger sharks means humans ain't
killing them.
Plus, they can breed for longer and age naturally.
Sharks aren't unique in this ability though,
corals, lizards, snakes, and amphibians all
grow continuously until they die -- all these
animals are "indeterminate growers," and they're
frickin' awesome.
Kangaroos and wallabies, slowly get bigger
as they age, until they're killed or die of
disease.
The Rocky Mountain bristlecone pine can live
for thousands of years, growing all the time.
A 2001 study of one tree found it hadn't had
a significant mutation in its pollen or seeds
over 4700 years.
At some point, the trees stop getting taller,
but continue to thicken at the trunk as long
as they have the resources.
Continuous growing is inextricably dovetailed
with aging.
Tortoises will keep getting larger, but super
slowly, and their internal organs suffer little
mutation over time.
The bristlecone pine does the same and simply
does not mutate over time.
Why?
We’re not really sure.
So even though sharks may live 70-plus years,
they WILL age and die naturally.
Some animals, like tortoises for example,
have what is called "Negligible Senescence,"
i.e. they don't appear to age at all; evolution
didn't program a natural limit to their lives.
With humans, tiny tails on our genes called
telomeres seem to be key to dictating a biological
end to our lives -- we've talked about this
in other DNews videos, If you were a subscriber,
you'd know that.
Some sharks, turtles, whales, and fish have
all identified as Negligibly Senescent and
many grow forever.
A Rougheye Rockfish was caught, and by looking
at it's growth periods -- like rings on a
tree -- they found it was 205 years old.
Just hanging out.
Lobsters will continue growing until preyed
upon or killed from disease, reproductive
competition or habitat destruction.
One 20 pound (9kg) specimen was found which
is believed to be 140 years old and another
was caught in 1926 weighing 51.5 lbs… how
old was it?
No idea.
They didn't save it.
They ate it.
Presumably with delicious, delicious butter.
By studying animals with indeterminate growth
and negligible senescence we've learned a
lot about the aging process, but also about
how resources can affect periods of growth.
Imagine if the longer we lived the more we
grew!
My 90-year-old grandma be huge!
I dunno, I kind of like being able to wear
the same shirts for 15 years or more…
Would you want to keep getting taller?
If we hadn't killed them, many of these animals
would still be around, just like the rhinoceros.
But unlike the giant kangaroo or super-lobster,
there's a crazy plan to save the rhino using
3D printing.
CTA to Seeker
Rhino 3D Printed Horn